شكرا عبد السلام واهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
وكما نشاهد على الشاشه الان هذه صور بعد
ان غادر الرئيس الامريكيه السابق دونالد
ترامب المحكمه الفيدراليه في ميامي بعدما
استمع ووضع قيد الاحتجاز واستمع الى
القاضيه وهي تتلو عليها التهم الموجهه
اليه السبع سبع وثلاثين تهمه قراتها
القاضيه على مسامع دونالد ترامب ومحاميه
ودفع ببراءته من التهم المنسوبه اليه جميع
هذا موكب الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب بعد
ما غادر المحكمه في ميامي في طريقه الى
نادي الجولف الذي يملكه في المدينه ذاتها
في ولايه فلوريدا الامريكيه وهي ولايه
صوتت لترامب وتصوت للجمهوريه منذ مده غير
قريبه اذا ما حدث اليوم مشاهدينا ان
الرئيس الامريكيه السابق دونالد ترامب
مثوله مثل امام محكمه الفيدراليه في ميامي
ووضع قيد الاحتجاز طوال فتره
هذه الجلسه حينما استمع الى القاضيه وهي
تتلو عليه 37 تهمه ودفع ببراءته من التهم
جميعا ليكون بذلك اول رئيس سابق بل اول
مرشح
للرئاسه يمثل امام محكمه فيدراليه امريكيه
في تهم منها تهم تتعلق بقانون التجسس
لحمايه الامن القومي الامريكي
تنظم متهم بمخالفه هذا القانون باحتفاضه
بوثائق سريه تمسوا الامن القوميه
الامريكيه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
بدو جلسات محاكمه فيدراليه هي الاولى في
تاريخ رؤساء الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
دونالد ترامب يخضع لاجراءات اعتقال مؤقت
مع مساعده السابق قبل الوصول امام القاضي
ويدفع ببراءته من عشرات التهم المتعلقه
بقضيه الوثائق السريه ويغادر المحكمه مع
منعه من الحديث مع اي شهود
في تحقيقه بشان عمليه العوجه التي قتل
فيها ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين بنيران مجند
مصري الجيش الاسرائيلي يحجم عن الحديث عن
ملابسات العمليه ويقر بالاخفاق في
الجاهزيه العسكريه يحمل مسؤوليه الخسائر
لقائد الفرقه الاسرائيليه على الحدود
ويقرر اغلاق كل الممرات الامنيه على
السياج الحدودي مع مصر
مواجهات بالاسلحه الثقيله في احياء غربي
الخرطوم وذوي انفجارات في ام درمان امريكي
يقول ان الطرفين النزاع يبددان فرصه
التفاوض المتاحه لهما ويكشف عن تشاور مع
الرياض لاعلان نهج جديد بشان السودان وقلق
امامي من تدهور الاوضاع في دارفور لاسيما
في الجنينه بعد موجه عوف اتخذ الطابعا
عرقيا
في تصريح غير مسبوق بوتين يقول ان روسيا
لم تكن مستعده بما فيه الكفايه لمواجهه
الهجمات الاوكرانيه عقب حديث روسيا عن ما
اعتبرتها خسائر كارثيه لاوكرانيا
تعلن تحقيق مكاسب في الهجوم المضاد وتؤكد
انها تتقدم وتقارير عن عزم اداره بايدن
تزويد اوكرانيا بقنابل اليورانيوم المنظم
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصات
الرقميه ناقشنا تداعيات هذه التهم التي
وجهت للرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
ومثولها امام محكمه الخيميامي تنظر في
عشرات التهم المتعلقه باساءه التعامل مع
الاسرار الحكوميه والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان
هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي برايكم ما حجم تاثير قضيه الوثائق
السريه على حظوظ في سباق الرئاسه
الامريكيه عشرون بالمئه قالوا لها ستؤثر
بشكل كبير 30% راوا ان تاثيرها محدود 50%
راهو ان القضيه لن تؤثر اطلاقا على فرص
ترامب في الانتخابات الامريكيه هذا السؤال
سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتهم الرقميه ويمكنكم
دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز الكيوار
الظاهر الان على الشاشه لقائنا على
المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله
لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون في الحصد ايضا اكثر من بيئه قتل
وعشرات الجرحى منذ مطلع العام هي حاصله
الجرائم العنف التي تفتكوا بالمواطنين
الفلسطينيين داخل الخط الاخضر
[موسيقى]
القاضيه الفيدراليه قررت منع ترامب من
التحدث الى شهود المحتمرين في القضيه
وقالت وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه ان ترامب
سيتوجه الى نيوجازي بعد مغادرته المحكمه
وسيوجه كلمه لان صالح
اذا هذا هو موكب الرئيس الامريكي دونالد
ترامب بعدما غادر المحكمه
والتي مثل فيها امام القاضيه الفيدراليه
هذا الموكب طبعا بعد مغادرته المحكمه بحسب
وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه سيتوجه الى
نيوجيرسي وربما
نستمع للكثير مما سيقوله بعد هذه القضيه
لكن موقف واضح من هذه القضيه برمتها من
اولها وهي انها قضيه سياسيه
وتستهدفه شخصيا وتستهدف فرصه في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه
وينضم الينا من امام المحكمه ميامي
الفيدراليه مراسله للجزيره احمد هزيم كما
تنضم الينا مراسله الجزيره من ميامي بيسان
ابو كويك اب ابدا بك احمد هزيم وملخص لما
جرى اليوم طبعا كل ما جرى هو غير مسبوق
وكل ما يجري في الواقع له صله بتشامبو
ومحاكمته وغير مسبوق ايضا في التاريخ
الامريكي لكن ما الذي جرى اليوم
نعم زين هي لحظات تاريخيه هو الرئيس
الامريكي سابق يخضع لي محاكمه فيدراليه
تتعلق بتهم جنائيه واتهم يتعلق بالامن
القومي ما جرى هو
قبل بدء موعد الجلسه بحوالي نصف ساعه وصل
موكب الرئيس الامريكي دخل الى القاعه وضع
رهن الاعتقال وجاء بيان مقتضب من وزاره
الامريكيه بان اجراءات وضع الرئيس
الامريكي راني لاعتقاد جرت كالمعتاد لكن
هذا التصريح فيه من الغموض ما فيه هل تم
وضع الاصفاد في يده كما يعد كما هو معتاد
ام انه كما تسرب سيكتفى فقط لاخذ بصماته
كما كان الحال عندما عرض على المحكمه في
ولايه نيويورك وضع رانا الاعتقال ثم ادخل
الى المحكمه تلت عليه لائحه الاتهام عرض
او دفع ببراءته منها ومن ثم ادت القاضيه
لتقول بان الرئيس الامريكي دونالد ترامب
لن يخضع لشروط مقابل الافراج عنه من السفر
ولا حتى
فرض كفاله علي انما فقط امرته بالا يتواصل
مع الشهود المحتملين للادعاء وغادر الرئيس
الامريكي قبل دقائق من مبنى المحكمه
باتجاه اولا ربما مقره في ميامي ومن ثم
الى نيوجيرسي حيث سيلقي كلمه في فعاليه
جمع تبرعات انتخابيه هناك في ولايه نيوجي
في بد من هذه القضيه الان بعد ان تم رسميا
توجيه هايتهم زين ابعاد عديده وابعاد
كثيره منها ما هو سياسي وهي المعركه التي
خاضها الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب ومحاموه وحتى مناصروه منذ الكشف بان
هناك تهم ستوجه له بالقول بان هذه التهم
هو استخدام لوزاره العدل من قبل اداره
بايرن كالسلاح انتخابي ضده يقضي الى تقويه
فرصه في الانتخابات المقبله وان هذه التهم
سياسيه وانه لم يرتكب اي جرم من هذه
الجرائم التي يقول الادعاء انه ارتكبها
وانه بوضعه كرئيس
رئيس سابق لديه التصريح الامني الذي يخوله
الاطلاع على هذه الوثائق هذه معركه من
جانب اخر المعركه الثانيه هناك المهتمون
بشؤون الامن القومي الامريكي الذين
ينتظرون من المرافعات ان تكشف ربما لماذا
اختار الرئيس الامريكي رونالد ترامب جمعا
هذه الكم الكبير من الوثائق السريه في مقر
اقامته وفي مناطق وغرف غير امنه البته
منها قاعات للرقص ومنها حتى حمام في في
بعض المقاره وضعت فيها صناديق من الوثائق
السريه لماذا اختار الرئيس ان ياخذ هذه
الوثائق السريه لماذا اصر على عدم تسليمها
ولماذا حاول تظليل محققين
هذه الوثائق ابعاد كثيره احمد ياسين فقط
الى هذه الصور
التي تظهر على شاشتنا الان وهو اول ظهور
لرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب بعد
خروجه من المحكمه ومثوله امامها اليوم ها
هو تشامب في جمع من مساعديه وربما انصاره
ايضا
لا يبدو من الصور اين هو
لكن يفترض ان يكون ما زال في فلوريدا لانه
سيتوجه بعد ذلك الى نيوجازي حيث سيلقي
كلمه كما اوضحت احمد هزيم لكن هذا اول
ظهور لدونالد ترامب الرئيس الامريكي
السابق والمرشح للرئاسه
لاول صور له بعد بثوله امام المحكمه نشاهد
هذه الصور ونستمع لما يقال فيها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لنلتقط صوره هو بطل حقيقي لا تقاتلوه
من عيد ميلاد لدينا حكومه خارجه عن
السيطره
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يا لها من رحله رائعه
[تصفيق]
اذا هذه صور تبعناها ونتابعها الان للرئيس
الامريكي دونالد تشامب في ميامي
بعد ان وصل الى هذا المكان
بعد مثوله امام المحكمه الفدراليه في ما
يميل لنستمع لما يقول الرئيس الامريكي
السابق
لدينا دوله ليس فيها
حدود ليس فيها سوى مشاكل ويفعلون ما
يفعلونه وترون الشعب ترون اننا نحب الشعب
ترون الحشود لدينا دوله في تقهر كما لم
يسبق ان رايناها من قبل
سوف ادلب خطاب الليله
وامل ان تكونوا حاضرين
انت ايضا يمكنك ان تحضر اضاءه شكرا جميعا
[تصفيق]
شكرا جزيلا باركك الله شكرا
اذا الصور للرئيس الامريكي دور تشام
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب اول
صور له بعد مثله
لاول مره وفي سابقه لاول رئيس امريكي سابق
امام محكمه فيدراليه في ميامي عاصمه ولايه
فلوريدا تحدث كما يبدو من الصور التي
اضعنا قبل قليل بثقه وبثقته في براءته
ووجه كيلا من الانتقادات للحكومه والاداره
الامريكيه الحاليه
نتوجه مره اخرى الى مراسلينا ونتوجه هذه
المره الى بسانه بو كويك في ميامي كان
يفترض ان يكون هنالك حشد كبير من انصار
دونالد ترامبو حشد مضاد فكيف كيف كيف كان
الحشد من الجانبين اليوم
كان سلميا
بالاطار العام ولكن كان هناك مشدات كلاميه
شهدناها على مدار اليوم وحتى شهدناها
بالامس خارج منتجع ترامب فيدورال ما بين
الطرفين
وطبعا الهتاف والهتاف المضاد ولكن لم تحدث
او تسجل اي اعمال عنف او او ضرب او اي شيء
اكثر من ذلك حين كانت ترامب على وشك
المغادره مغادره المحكمه تجمهره طبعا
مناصروها الذين يدفعون ببراءه كانوا
يهتفون بانهم يحبون ترامب بانه يجب ان لا
يتعرض لما يسمونه بهذه الملاحقه القضائيه
المسيسه من قبل وزاره عدد مسيسه وفق قولهم
الطرف الاخر يقول ان ترامب انتهك الدستور
ليس فقط في هذه القضيه بل قضايا اخرى ويجب
ان يحاسب وانا لا احد فوق القانون
مشدات ومشهد من الهرج والمرج ولكن لم يكن
اي من ذلك
يعني فيه اي نوع من العنف او مثلا مثلا
اضطرت الشرطه للتدخل وما شاهدناه هنا ربما
حتى مختلف عن نيويورك حين تم فصل
المجموعتين هنا المجموعتين كانوا مختلطين
مع بعضهم البعض ومع الصحفيين طبعا الرئيس
السابق يتوجه للاحتفال بعيد ميلاده في
منتجع منتجعه او مقره في نيوجيرسي في حفل
لجمع التبرعات لحملته الانتخابيه توقف قبل
قليل في مطعم كوبي هنا في ميامي حيث اجتمع
مع عدد من مناصريه راينا الصور ولذا سنسمع
منه طبعا الكثير ولكن كما نعلم ان موقفه
واضح من هذه القضيه منذ اللحظه التي اعلن
هو
ولكن في مواقع ومراكز الاف بي اي في عده
ولايات
هذا ربما ستظل وسائل الامن وجهات الامن
وقوات الامن وانفاذ القانون ترصده يعني
حتى ربما تهدئ الامور
وننتظر السماع من ترامب بنفسه الليله ما
سيقوله وان كان سيدلب جديد تحدثت سريعا مع
صحفي كان داخل القاعه قبل قليل وقال لي
انا ترامب متجهما داخل القاعه وهو متوقع
ولكنه كان هادئ وحتى حين يعني ادار بوجهه
الى وسائل الاعلام وطبعا تمنع الصور وتمنع
الكاميرات بداخل كان متجهما اكثر حين راى
عدد من وسائل الاعلام وذلك وفقا لاحد
الصحفيين الذين التقيته هنا وكان يتحدث عن
الاجواء داخل القاعه زين
لسان وانت معنا ايضا نتابع هذه الصور
لموكب الرئيس الامريكي وهو يغادر هذا
المطعم الكوبي في ميامي
متوجها الى المطار فيما يبدو مطار ميامي
ثم بعد ذلك الى ان يجازي حيث يحضر في حفل
في حفل عيد ميلاده هي الذي يعتبر ايضا
مناسبه لجامع حمله التبرعات
لحملته الانتخابيه شكرا لك الرساله
بالكويك من ميامي وشكر ايضا لاحمد هزيم
ومعنى من واشنطن
مدير الاتصالات والاعلام السابق في الحزب
الديمقراطي ومعنى كذلك بيتر روف الكاتب
الصحفي في مجله والقياده في اللجنه
الوطنيه للحزب الجمهوري وابدا بالسيد بيتر
روف كانت هنالك امال بان يكون الحشد كبيرا
لمناصره الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب لكن
هذا لم يحدث ما السبب
اعتقد انه من الضروري ان ياتي او حشد كبير
دفاع او دعما للمتهم في قاعه محكمه حتى لو
كان مرشحا رئاسيا نتحدث عن عصر يوم
الثلاثاء الناس لديهم حياتهم واعمالهم هذا
لا يشير الى قله الدعم اذا نظرنا الى معظم
اذا استطلاعات الراي فان الدعم قد ارتفع
منذ ان انتشرت اخبار توجيه لائحه الاتهام
وبالتالي ليس صحيحا القول ان عدم وجود
حشود كبيره يعني انه خسر الدعم
فيما يتعلق بنفيه كل التهم المنسوبه اليه
هل هل هذا يؤشر على ان الدفاع قادر على ان
يبراهم من هذه التهم سيد رف
ع
يجب ان ننتظر لنرى اي قضيه سوف
يقدم الادعاء هناك الكثير من النقاط هنا
التي فعلا تعتبر
حديثه بالنسبه الى امتلاكه وثائق وعدم
تعامله معها بالطريقه الملائمه
هذه كلها تهم لم او بالاحرى
قوانين وقواعد
نادرا ما تستخدم بالنسبه الى قانون العام
1917 موضوع
كوريا الشماليه
بالنسبه الى ايضا
قانون السجلات الرئاسيه حيث ان الكثير من
الادارات قد او لم تتفق حول ما يجب ان
يذهب الى الارشيف والمرتبه الوطنيه ويجب
الرئيس ان يحتفظ به اذا هناك مقوله مفادها
انه يمكن توجه لائحه اتهام حتى لشطيره
ديك رومي وهذا ما فعلوه فعلا هنا
يمكن توجيه اتهام لشطيره ديك رومي لكن
التهم الموجهه لدونالد ترامب هل هي كذلك
سيد جون
لائحه الاتهام هنا فعلا غريبه كما اشار
سيد بيتر سند الى قانون قديم
نادره ما كان يستخدم ولكن الوقائع المثاره
في هذه اللائحه القصه التي يرويها ترويها
اللائحه عن سلوكيات ترامب حين غادر البيت
الابيض حين اخرج صناديقا وصناديق مختلفه
وحين اتت الحكومه الفيدراليه وقالت له هذه
ليست لك عليك ان تعيدها بدا يكذب ويحرك
هذه الصناديق
ويتصرف بطريقه حتى طفوليه من اجل ان يخرج
صناديق احيانا كان فيها وثائق سريه
لابد من ان الوكالات الاستخباريه عملت
عليها جاهزه اعتقد ان الموضوع القانونيه
لا يزال غير معروفه الاستراتيجيه
القانونيه لم تكشف لا نعرف لماذا وجهت هذه
التهم بالتحديث هذه المرحله ولكن كل هذا
بامكانه ان يتغير ويتحول حين تبدا
المحاكمه يبدو ان المدعي العام لديه عدد
كبير من الادله الوثائقيه شهود عيان فيه
اشرطه تظهر سلوكيات ترامب السيئه بطريقه
تقوي ذو امنا الوطني وحتى لو لم تقوده هي
اصلا غير شرعيه غير قانونيه ولا يتوقع احد
من شخص راشد ان يتصرف بهذه الطريقه
هل تعتقد ان الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
سيستفيد ام سيتضرر من هذه القضيه
هناك حجه سياسيه واخرى قانونيه الحجه
القانونيه اولا السلوك السيء ليس جريمه لو
كان كذلك فان نصفه
ومعظم اعضاء الكونغرس يدخلون السجن
السلوك السيء هو سيليكون سيء ليس غير
قانوني
بالنسبه الى الموضوع السياسي
هناك نمط
مقلق في سنه الخمسين الاخيره لوزاره العدل
التي تستخدم مواردها من اجل الفوز بقضايا
بدلا من ان تلاحقا فعلا المجرمين
تقوم باحقاق الحق انا لست محاميا وبالتالي
قد لا اتمكن من شرح ذلك تقنيا وفنيا كما
يفعل اي محامي ولكن الهدفا نهائي لنائب
العام للمدعي العام الذي يمثل الحكومه
التي تمثل الشعب الولايات المتحده في اي
قديه فيدراليه هو ان يسعى الى احقاق الحق
العداله وليس الحصول على ادانه لدينا
قواعد في القانون الامريكي مفادها انه اذا
كان الادعاء قد كشف دليلا
يذهب الى مصلحات المتهم مطلوب منه عليه ان
يعطيه الى هذا لا يمكنه لا يمكنه ان يحافظ
على سريته او ينتظر حتى المتهم يكشف بنفسه
انا ارى انا انا لائحه الاتهام التي تلاها
سيد سميث
ليس الهدف منها الخروج
بالنتيجه موسفه وعادله الهدف منها والحصول
على ادانه او على الاقل
مشهد معين مهرجان معين محاكمه ان كانت شمس
سيستفيد ام سيتضرر من ذلك
السياسه غير بعيده كما يقول ضيفنا عن هذه
القضيه هل هي في مصلحه ترامب ام ضد مصلحه
ترامب لاسيما وانا استطلاعات الراي قد قد
تقول شيئا مختلفا عما يتوقع الكثيرون
اعتقد ان هناك سياق سياسي وتاريخي لدى لشك
في ذلك دعونا لا ننسى لا لم يكن بالامكان
محاكمته حين كان رئيسا ولكن
من البيت الابيض
اول محاميه مايكل كوين دخل السجن لتامر
معه هذه الجريمه الاولى الجريمه الثانيه
هو
معتمد محاكمته ونيابيا للعزل المراه
الاولى وهي المساعده من قبل رئيس اجنبي
وثالثا تصرفاته في السادس مليانه الكثير
من المعاصيري هم في السجن وهم وهو الذي
حرضهم على ذلك اذا فكره ان وزاره العدل في
عهد بايدن قاسي عليه غير صحيح ما حصل الان
هو ان ترامب اخذ اشياء لا تعود له طلب منه
مرارا وتكرارا بطريقه مهذبه ولطيفه وغيرها
لم يعدها نتحدث هنا عن برامج استخباريه
طورت هذه المعلومات ووجب انهاء هذه
البرامج لانه احتفظ بهذه الوثائق بطريقه
غير مشروعه اذا هي ليست جريمه شطيره ديك
رومي هنا هي جريمه فعليه
انا فكره ان
او فكره القول ان ترامب يعامل بطريقه غير
منصفه بصراحه طلب منه اكثر من مره ان يعيد
هذه الوثائق في مكه من واشنطن
في الحزب الديمقراطي ونشكر ايضا من واشنطن
مدير تحرير الكاتب الصحفي في مجله نيوزويك
والقياده في اللجنه الوطنيه للحزب
الجمهوري
[موسيقى]
خلصت نتائج وتحقيقات الجيش الاسرائيلي في
عمليه معبر العوجه الحدوديه مع مصر الثالث
من الشهر الجاري الى وجود عده اخفاقات
واكد قائد القياده الجنوبيه بالجيش
الاسرائيليزر توليدانو ضروره تصحيحها
واستخلاص العبر منها وقد قرر الجيش
الاسرائيلي سد الممرات الامنيه المقامه في
السياج الحدودي على طول الحدود مع مصر كما
قرر تقليص مده مناوبه الجنود في نقاط
المراقبه من 12 ساعه الى ثمان ساعات فقط
ومن جانب اخر فرض رئيس هيئه اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي هارت سهاليفي عقوبات على عدد
من ضباط الجيش العاملين في القياده
الجنوبيه
معنى من النصر جاكي خوري الكاتب المختص في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه ما الذي كشفه هذا
التحقيق الاسرائيلي
مساء الخير لك
ولدين يعني هو عمليا بالازاز كشف بعض
الاخفاقات في المنظومه الامنيه والعسكريه
الاسرائيليه
المتعلقه بالموقع نفسه لنتحدث فيها البعد
الاستراتيجي والعسكري بالنسبه يعني الجيش
الاسرائيلي في هذه المنطقه حسب التقارير
التي نشرت في الساعات الاخيره وبيان الجيش
الاسرائيلي تحدث ان القوه التي تواجدت في
المنطقه عمليا لم تعلم بوجود فتحات في
الشريط
ان تستخدم هذه الفتحات مثلا لدخول او خروج
من يخطط لذلك اذا كانت لديه معلومات مسبقه
خاصه عندما نتحدث عن عناصر امن من الطرفين
ناهيك عن كشف مثلا بعض عيوب صحه التعبير
في كل ما يرتبط بقرار القيادات العسكريه
في المنطقه على مستوى قائد الكتيبه وقائد
الوحده وكذلك قائد وحده الصف في الجيش
الاسرائيلي التي عملت في المنطقه وايضا
بالنسبه لساعات الورديه ساعات العمل او
ساعات الخدمه للفرقه التي كانت في المنطقه
هناك وبالتالي زادت علي عشره ساعه
وبالتالي اعتبرت اللجنه التحقيق التي بحثت
في هذا الامر ان هنالك بعض الخروقات التي
تمت وعليه اتخذ القرار مثلا
ببعاد قائد
اللواء في المنطقه وكذلك توجيه الرسائل
توبيخ لعدد من الضباط الكبار ولكن لا
نتحدث عن الرتب الاعلى في منطقه الجنوب
نتحدث عن قيادات من الدرجه الثانيه
والثالثه بالاضافه الى بعض التوصيات
المتعلقه بنشاط الجنود في المنطقه وساعات
عملهم وبالاضافه مثلا الى تعزيز التواجد
عن النظره
ماذا عن النظره لهذه الحدود باعتبرها
حدودا امنه مع دوله صديقه
يعني الحدود هي حدود امنه وما زالت النظره
بنفس الموضوع خاصه ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
ابرز عده مرات ان هنالك تناغم وتنسيق كامل
مع القوات المسلحه المصريه بما في ذلك
القياده في المنطقه وحتى اعلن بشكل رسمي
عن زياره لكبار الضباط في لواء الجنوب
وكذلك في وحده العمليات للقاهره ولقائهم
مع نظرائهم المصريين للبحث في هذا الامر
بمعنى لا يوجد هنالك اي جو يشير توتر في
العلاقه او تغيير
العلاقه انا اتحدث على النظر على الحدود
بما انها هناك جنود تابعون للسلطات
المصريه فلا يتوقع منهم خطر هل هذه النظره
تغيرت الان
لا لم تتغير اعتقد
لماذا يغلق الممر ممر الطوارئ ولماذا يتم
تغيير
الاولويات في منطقه الجنوب من مكافحه
المخدرات فقط الى توقع عمليات من هذا
النوع من الجنود المصريين
يعني اولا لا ننسى يجب ان نتعامل مع هذا
الموضوع في مسارين المسار الاول ما يرتبط
بالعلاقات مع الجيش المصري وكما ذكرت
هنالك محاوله اسرائيليه حديثه لاعاده
الامور الى نصابها بل تعزيز التنسيق بين
الطرفين بمعنى لا يوجد اي توجه اسرائيلي
الى ان الحدود الان غير امنه بمفهوم ان
هنالك جهه لا تستطيع ان تؤتمن على الطرف
الاخر من الحدود ليس هذا هو المشهد ما حصل
بنسبه بوجهه نظر اسرائيليه ان هنالك اخفاق
حصل على مستوى الوحده وعلى مستوى النشاط
العسكري في المكان عدم الاوامر العسكريه
التقرير يتحدث عن اخفاق في توقع مثل هذه
العمليات
هذا صحيح ولكن انا يعني حتى لا نرفع سقف
التوقعات انا لا اقول انا لم يكن هنالك
اخفاق كان هنالك اخفاق وجهه نظر اسرائيليه
وانا اقول لك اكثر من ذلك انه ذلك نقاش
داخلي في اسرائيل عن تواجد يعني جندي
مجنده في نفس الوحده وفي نفس ساعات الخدمه
لا يتحدثون الان ببعد ان هنالك امر خطير
على المستوى الامني وانه هنالك شيء جدري
تغير وتحول في التوجه الاسرائيلي والمصرف
العلاقات بين الطرفين خاصه في مسؤوليه
يعني كل طرف عن حدوده وتامين الحدود نعم
هنالك اخفاقات وهذا واضح هنالك ثلاثه جنود
قتله لا ننسى ايضا ان العمليه التي تمت
بعد استهداف الجنديين وما حصل هناك بمعنى
ان هناك اخفاق في عدم استخدام الطائرات
اذا كانت الطائرات المسيره او طائرات
الهليكوبتر في المنطقه بالاضافه الى
الاجراءات المتعلقه بالوحده التي تعمل
هناك هنالك امرين منفصلين البعد
الاستراتيجي
والعلاقات بين البلدين والتنسيق بين
الطرفين ان اقول لك لم يتغير وهذا واضح
وبالتالي ابراز ايضا ما ذكرت قبل لحظات ان
هنالك زيارات وهنالك تنسيق وهنالك نقاط
على اعلى مستوى تمت في هذا الموضوع بما في
ذلك الاتصال للهاتف بين رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه نتنياهو بين الرئيس المصري
عبد الفتاح السيسي بعد ذلك لاتصال مع
الكثير الامن الاسرائيلي ونظيره المصري
وصولا الى وصول الى وجود امن اسرائيلي في
القاهره
من النصره شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
نقلت وكاله رويترز عن مسؤول في الخارجات
الامريكيه قوله ان طرفي الصراع في السودان
لا ينتهي ذلك محادثات جدا التي اتيحت لهما
واوضح المسؤول الامريكي ان محادثات جده لا
تحقق نجاحا فيما يتعلق بالتوصل لوقف دائم
للقتال بالسودان ونقلت رويترز ايضا عن
مسؤول الخارجيه الامريكيه قوله الى واشنطن
تتشاور مع الرياض وشركاء اخرين بشان
السودان وتتوقع اعلان دهج جديد
اكد مسئول سودانيه ان قائد الجيش عبد
الفتاح البرهان لن يلتقي قائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان حببتي وذلك غداه اعلاني
كينيا سعيها لترتيب لقاء بينهما وقال
المسؤول الذي رفض الكشف عن اسمه لوكاله
فرانس قال ان اللقاء لا يتم في ظل الظروف
الراهنه كما اشار المسؤول السوداني الى ان
قياده الجيش ومجلس السياده لديهما تحفظات
عده على بيان قمه الايجاد التي عقلت في
جيبوتي يوم امس وقالت وزاره الخارجيه
السودانيه ان وفد بلادها ابدع اعتراضه على
عدد من الفقرات في مساواه البيان الختامي
لعدم مناقشتها والاتفاق عليها
وفي التطورات المعارك فادى مراسل الجزيره
باستخدام اسلحه ثقيله في اشتباكات قرب
المنطقه الصناعيه وحيي الرميله والحله
الجديده غرب الخرطوم كما سمع عدوي
انفجارات في ام درمان وشهد تصاعد لاعمله
الدخان وتحليق للطائرات الحربيه في سماء
مدن الخرطوم والخرطوم بحري وام درمان
قال رئيس البعثه الامميه المتكامله لدعم
المرحله الانتقاليه في السودان فولكرم
بورتس ان الوضع الامنيه والانسانيه في
حاله تدهور سريع في جميع انحاء السودان لا
سيما الخرطوم الكبرى ودارفور وكردفان واكد
بارتس مقتله واصابه الاف المدنيين
بالسودان وقال ان المعلومات الوارده ترسم
صورته واضحه لنطاق التاثير المدمر على
السكان المدنيين واضاف بارتس بان
المجتمعات تعاني من نقص حاد في الغذاء
والحصول على الامدادات الطبيه وتقييد
الحركه خارج مناطق النزاع كما اشار الى
نزوحي مئات الالاف من السودان من
السودانيين وعبر عن قلقه بشان الادعاءات
المتعلقه بالعنف الجنسي ضد النساء
والفتيات
ومن جانب اخر قال بارتس ان موجات العنف
اتخذت ابعادا عرقيه في دارفور وبشكل خاص
في مدينه الجنينه وانها تستهدف المدنيين
على اساس هوياتهم العرقيه ما يثير قلقا
عميقا
[موسيقى]
لاحقا في فقره المتابعه نسلط الضوء على
المعارك الجاريه خارج الخرطوم وتحديدا في
دارفور ونزل ضيف الحصاد عن التداعيات
المحتمله لاتساع نطاق الاضطرابات بالسودان
[موسيقى]
الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اكد الرئيس
على بلاده محاربه ما وصفهم بعملاء العدو
واضاف بوتين في لقاء مع مراسلين عسكريين
مؤيدين للكرملين انه كان بالامكان
الاستعداد بشكل افضل للهجمات على المناطق
الحدوديه الروسيه ولوح انه اذا استمرت
الهجمات فعلى روسيا ان تفكر في ايجاد
منطقه عازله داخل اوكرانيا وقال انه لا
ضروره لاعلان الاحكام العرفيه في روسيا
ولكن لابد وفق قوله من العمل على بعض
المسائل بشكل ادق وقال ان الهجوم
الاوكرانيه المضاده الذي بدا في الرابع من
يونيو الجاري يجري من محاور مختلفه واشار
الى ان خسائر روسيا عشر خسائر الطرف
المهاجم وهدد بوتين باستخدام اسلحه تحتوي
على اليوراني بالمنظم لو استدعت الضروره
ذلك ردا على استخدامها ضد بلاده حسب قوله
لكنه قال بالمقابل ان روسيا مستعده
لمحادثات السلام ان اراد الاخرون لكن ما
يسعون اليه الان هو هزيمه روسيا واكد ان
لدى بلاده خطتها للسلام بشان اوكرانيا ولم
ترفض مطلقا محادثات قد تقود الى تسويه
سلميه واضافت في نفس السياقه ان مفتاح
الحل للصراع بين الغرب وسبيل انهائه هو
وقف تزويد اوكرانيا بالسلاح
قال الرئيس بيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكاشينكو
انه لن يتردد في استخدام السلاح النووي
اذا تعرضت بلاده لاي اعتذار واوضح انه هو
من طلب من بوت النشر هذه الاسلحه التي
اعتبرها وسيله للردع وفي المقابل كشفت
صحيفه هول ان من المتوقع ان تزود اداره
بايدن اوكرانيا بقنابل اليورانيوم المنظم
ونقله بعض المسؤولين الامريكيين ان هدفهم
هو تمكين اوكرانيا من تحقيق اكبر قدر ممكن
من التقدم في ساحه المعركه
رئيس بيلاروسيا يلوح باستخدام السلاح
النووي يقول انه لن يتردد في ذلك اذا
تعرضت بلاده لاي اعتداء قبل ايام استقبله
الرئيس الروسي في منتجع السوتشي واعلن ان
البنيه التحتيه لتخزينها للاسلحه النوويه
التكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا ستصبح جاهزه في
السابع من الشهر القادم لتنقل الاسلحه بعد
ذلك بقليل تستخدم الاسلحه النوويه
التكتيكيه لتدمير التشكيلات العسكريه
والاسلحه في ارض المعركه مداها قصير نسبيا
وقوتها النوويه اقل بكثير من الرؤوس
النوويه التي توضع على الصواريخ الباليسيه
تعتقد الحكومه الامريكيه ان روسيا تملك
الفيس سلاح نووي تكتيكي ينظر الغرب لنقل
هذه الاسلحه الى بيلاروسيا كتهديد النووي
روسي ليس لاوكرانيا وحدها ولكن لكل اوروبا
لكن روسيا ايضا تتهم الغرب باستخدام
النووي في حرب اوكرانيا تشير موسكو الى
دول غربيه اوكرانيا بذخائر اليورانيوم
المنظف ويلوح الرئيس بوتين باستخدامها اذا
استدعت الضروره ردا على استخدامها ضد
قواته صحيفه جورنال كشفت عن استعداد البيت
الابيض لمد اوكرانيا بهذه الذخائر ونقلت
عن مسؤول امريكي ان البانتاجون يريد
تسليمها مع دبابات ابرمس استخدام
اليورانيوم المنظم في هذه الذخائر يمكن من
اختراق الدبابات والدروع بسهوله اكبر حيث
تصطدم قذيفه اليورانيوم المنظف بالهدف
لتحترق ذاتيا في درجه حراره عاليه تنبعث
معها جزيئات اليورانيوم متناهيه الصغر في
الغلاف الجوي ويستخدم اليونانم المنظم في
القذائف التي تطلق من دبابات تشالنجر
البريطانيه وابرز الامريكيه
الى
الالمانيه انتقدت موسكو بشده تقديم
بريطانيا هذه الدخائر الى اوكرانيا مع
شحنه دبابات تشالنجر اثنين اعتبرت لندن
حديثه موسكو عن سلاح نووي تضليلا وفقا
لمعهد الامم المتحده لبحوث نزع السلاح لا
يمكن اعتبار ذخيره اليورانيوم المنظم
اسلحه نوويه لانه لا يولد تفاعلا نوويا
ولا يدخل تحت التعريف القانوني للاسلحه
النوويه لكن خبراء البيئه والصحه العامه
يرون انه يمكن ان يؤدي الى حساسيه في
الجلد وفشل الكلى ويزيد من مخاطر الاصابه
بالسرطان اذا مع انطلاق الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد يعود سجال السلاح النووي الذي يبقى
حتى الان ورقه للضغط
وفي التطورات الميدانيه قالت الاداره
العسكريه
فيسكن احد عشر شخصا قتلوا عصب 28 في قصف
روسي استهدف احد المباني في مدينه كريفيري
جنوب شرقي اوكرانيا وقد وصف الرئيس
الاوكراني فلودي القصف بالارهابي وحمل
روسيا المسؤوليه عن كل صاروخ اطلقت
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه عن حزمه مساعدتنا
امنيه جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه 30025 بليون
دولار تتضمن هذه الحزمه مزيدا من الاسلحه
والمعدات بغيه دعم القوات الاوكرانيه وقال
بلينكل في بيان ان الحزمه الجديده تتضمن
قدرات الدفاع جوي وذخائر اضافيه لانظمه
هاي مارس وطلقات مدفعيه واسلحه مضاده
للدبابات بالاضافه لمركبات مدرعه
دع رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي الى اشتراك
جهاز المخابرات الداخليه المعروف بالشباك
في مكافحه جرائم القتل التي تشهدها القرى
والبلدات الفلسطينيه داخل الخط الاخضر وقد
رفضت القياده العربيه داخل الخط الاخضر
دعوه نتنياهو معتبره ان تدخل الشباك سيفتح
المجال للتجسس على المجتمع الفلسطيني
وتشير الاحصاءات الى ارتفاع عدد الجرائم
القتل في المجتمع العربي بشكل كبير منذ
مطلع العام الجاري
هي صرخه ام فتله بل انها صرخه مجتمع
باكمله تقض الجريمه المنظمه مضجعه هذه
الايام
مش مجروحه موت ابنها انا وحده من الامراض
اللي قلبها
اكثر وحده
صعب الي يعني انا كنت في المستشفى انا
بايدي
فهنا في تقاعس من الجهه الامنيه لانه
اصبحت
اولادنا ارقام وملفات منسيه
يغيب الامن عن شوارع المدن والقرى العربيه
داخل الخط الاخضر ويكاد لا ينقضي يوم دون
عنف او جريمه قتل تشير الاحصائيات الى
ارتفاع عدد الضحايا خلال حكومات بنيامين
نتنياهو المتعاقبه اما اليوم فهو يدعو الى
اشراك جهاز المخابرات الداخليه المعروف
بالشبك في التحقيق بهذه الجرائم
انا مصر على اشراك جهاز الشباك فورا في
المعركه هذه هي الخطوه المطلوبه لاعاده
الامن التي يطوق له المواطنون العرب في
اسرائيل
يثير هذا التوجه جدلا في المجتمع المدني
ويحذر البعض من اثاره على حريه الفرد كما
يلقم انتقادات قانونيه تتعلق بكشف اساليب
عمل المخابرات ووسائلها التجسسيه ويرفض
الفلسطينيون داخل الخط الاخضر اي دور
لجهاز الشبك الان تخلي الشباب وربطه في
مساله العنف لكي نكون هناك تغلغل لمنظومه
الشباب داخل وسط العربي وتفكيكها من
الداخل والتجسس عليها وهذا ان دلفه ويدل
بنهايه الامر على انهم يرون بنا اعداء
ويتعاملون معنا من منطلق امن ياتي هذا في
وقت تتعالى فيه اصوات في المعارضه تدعو
الى اقاله وزير الامن القومي التمر بن جير
وتتهمه بانه غير معني بمكافحه الجريمه
بينما يتهم ساسه اخرون جهاز المخابرات
بالتواطئ مع العصابات الاجراميه يبدو
الفلسطينيون داخل الخط الاخضر امام واقع
مريء ويرون ان تقاعص الشرطه وتواطؤ جهاز
المخابرات مع قاده الجريمه المنظمه دليل
على ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه معنيه بتفتيت
مجتمعهم من الداخل وجعل قراهم ومدنهم
اماكن غير قابله للعيش لياسكال الجزيره
مدينه ام الفحم
[موسيقى]
خريطه الاقتتال بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع بدات تتسع وتمتد وتطول في
ولايات اخرى خارج الخرطوم وهو ما يزيد من
تعقيدات الصرع الدائر منذ شهور ومن
تداعياته الكثيره والخطيره على مستقبل
وحده البلاد وامن شعبها وصلت نار الاقتتال
الى مدينه الجنينه في الرابع والعشرين من
ابريل للسنه الماضي وهي الان من اسوا
مناطق الاشتباكات خارج الخرطوم طبعا
الجنينه عاصمه ولايه غرب دارفور تتعرض
لحصار مطبق كذلك من قوات الدعم السريع وهي
تعاني عزله تامه تحرمها المياه والكهرباء
وسط انباء عن سقوط عدد كبير من القتلى
والجرحى في هذه المدينه ذلك مدينه اخرى
مدينه زلنجي عاصمه ولايه وسط دارفور هذه
المدينه
هنالك حصار لهذه المدينه تماما ايضا من
قبل قوات الدعم
السريع بحسب ما جاء من انباع حيث نصبت
عشرات نقاط التفتيش على الطرق المؤديه الى
التحالف الخاص بهذه المنطقه من قبائل
وعشائر قال ان عشرات القتلى والجرحى سقطوا
ووصف الاوضاع الانسانيه في المدينه
بالكارثيه تسع قوات الدعم السريع للسيطره
على هذه المدينه الاستراتيجيه والتي تربط
ولايات الغرب بالعاصمه الخرطوم ووضع يدها
على مطار المدينه الذي يستخدم في بعض
الاحيان للطيران الحربي ونتحدث هنا تحديدا
عن مدينه الابيض في ولايه كوردفان مدينه
الاوبيض مهمه لكسب نقاط اضافيه في المعارك
الدائره حاليا اذ يربط دعم السريع الى خفض
الامداد عن العاصمه الخرطوم بعد ان فشل في
معركه مدينه مروي شمال البلاد
الخرطوم ودرفور والابيض تعد اكثر المناطق
تاثرا على المستوى الصحي والانساني والنقص
الكبير في الخدمات الاساسيه
وتداعيات الصراع الدائر في السودان منذ
ابريل لسان الماضي تعيش اوضاعا كارثيه على
جميع الصعود ويزيد من تفاقم الازمات
الانسانيه
بسبب استمرار الحرب وغياب اي مصدر مستقل
لحصر الضحايا والجرحى
لليونيسيف اكثر من 13 مليون طفل في حاجه
ماسه لدعم الانساني المنقذ للحياه في
السودان وهو اعلى رقم مسجل بالبلاد منذ
بدايه الصراع في 15
ابريل نيسان الماضي
المفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين تقول انما بين 60 الى 90 الفا
فروا الى تشاد المجاوره منذ لشوب القتال
رقابه الاطباء في وقت سابق كشفت عن مقتل
التسعه من اطبائها وطلابي كليه الطب خلال
الاشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم السريع كما
اكدت ايضا احدث تقاريرها خروج 70% من
المستشفيات المتاخمه لمناطق الاشتباكات عن
الخدمه
من اصل 85 مستشفى اساسي في العاصمه
والولايات يوجد 61 مستشفى فقط متوقف عن
الخدمه وخمسه وعشرون تعمل بشكل كامل او
جزئي بعضها يقدم اسعافات الاوليه فقط وهي
مهدده كذلك بالاغلاق ايضا بسبب نقص
الكوادر والامدادات الطبيه والتيار
الكهربائي
للمزيد عن ما يجري في السودان وتدعيات هذه
الحرب لسيمه في مناطق خارج الخرطوم نتحدث
عن دارفور وابيض ينضم الينا في الاستوديو
الدكتور اسامه عيدروس
المحلل والخبير الاكاديمي السوداني المختص
بالشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه مرحبا دكتور
اسامه اهلا بك يعني تحدثنا مرارا قبل ذلك
عن ان الوضع خارج الخرطوم الوضع في
الخرطوم سيء لكن خارج الخرطوم كارثي
ما الذي يجعل الصراع بهذا العنف
وبهذه الدمويه في مناطق الجنينه
كازالنجي
ايضا الاوبيض
فعلا
الصراع يختلف عما يدور في الخرطوم يعني
الخرطوم على الاقل بدات كحرب منظمه
بقياده واحده
بتحركها معروفه طرفها معروفان الذي حدث
يعني في مناطق دارفور انه من بدايه الصراع
تحركت الادارات الاهليه
المجتمع المدني المحلي والحركات المسلحه
ايضا التي وقعت على سلام جبا ووصلت الى
معادله تضمن يعني هدنه بشكل ما بحيث توقفت
دعم السريع المهاجمه الجيش في هذه
المناطق يعني الا ما ندر من احداث خصوصا
المتعلقه بصرف رواتبهم يعني وهذه الاشياء
بعدها يعني في لحظه ما كان الدعم السريع
فقد التواصل مع واصبحت القيادات الميدانيه
الموجوده في دارفور تتحرك لوحدها وفقه
اجنده مختلفه بعيده عن الحرب الدائره في
الخرطوم في الجنينه مثلا
الحرب بين المكونات القبليه اكثر من انها
بين الجيش والدعم السريع يعني ما الذي يرد
تحقيقه يعني من يدخل هذه الحرب ويقتل
الناس بهذه الاعداد ويحاصرهم ويميتهم جوعا
ما الذي يريد ان يحققه هل هو السيطره على
دارفور هل هو عزل دارفور بولاياتها عن
بقيه السودان مثلا ما المراد تحقيق
المساحه اولا هي مساحه واسعه جدا يعني
السيطره عليها لا يمكن ان تتاتى بهذه
السهوله المكونات المجتمعيه الموجوده فيها
من التعقيد بشكل كبير لكن الصراع قديم
واحده من من الاسباب التي يعني جعلت
الصراع بهذا الحده يعني
التحول هذه المجموعات للصراع على السلطه
يعني في في الماضي كانت المجموعات المسماه
بالمجموعات العربيه او السلطه في دارفور
في كل الاماكن يعني هي يعني كانوا بعيدين
من السلطه
مناطق الجنينه مثلا ولايه غرب
دارفور لم يكونوا لهم وجود في المناصب
التنفيذيه والسياسيه بدات هذه الاشياء
تظهر بعد تفجر حرب دارفور في 2003 هذا
المشهد هل يمكن لملمته هل يمكن العوده عنه
ام انه خلق واقعا جديدا على اي من سيتولى
السلطه في السودان اذا حسمت
جدا يعني هذه يعني الان جرائم ترتكب في
الجنينه لا يمكن ان نقول اننا سنتجاوزها
هكذا بسهوله
تحتاج الى كثير من الحكمه تحتاج الى كثير
من الحكماء للتدخل لوقف الاقتتال يعني
اصبحت اشكاله غريبه جدا يعني حرق لغراب
الكامل تدميرا للناس يعني قتل على الهويه
على على العرق
وتحشيد قبلي كبير جدا في هذه المناطق
هذه المساله لها مردودات ما بعد الحرب
يعني ايا كانت نتيجه الحرب في الخرطوم
فسيكون الوضع صعب جدا
في هذا من الصعب من الصعب انها تهدا
بسهوله تحتاج الى حكمه كبيره جدا لتجاوزها
وكثير من الوقت لنتحدث عن الجانب السياسي
وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه في بيان تحفظت
على تقول ان قياده الجيش ومجلس السياده
متحفظ على مبادره الايجاد ما الاسباب ما
اسباب التحفظ على مبادره الايجاع اقليم
الايجاد نفسه يتكون من مجموع الدول ضعيفه
ليس من بينها دوله مهيمنه او مسيطره يعني
اذا نظرت الى غرب افريقيا مثلا وجود
نيجيريا احدث قدر من الاستقرار في الاقليم
باعتبارها الدوله الكبيره المسيطره
والمهيمنه هذه الدول متداخله في بعضها
يعني قريبا جدا من الصراع الداير في
الخرطوم كان هنالك صراع دائري
الجيش غير محايده غير مؤهله هي يعني الت
داخل وبين قوه اقليميه وقوه دوليه اخرى
يعني اثيوبيا مثلا رفضت وساطه السودان في
حرب التجريه ورفض التدخل اي دوله في حربه
الى ان انتهت الحرب فيما يتعلق بالموقف
الامريكي ايضا لان محادثات جده لم تحقق ما
هو مطلوب وانه سيكون هنالك نهج جديد ما
توقعاتك للنهج الجديد
لو انهم يتوجهوا الى مع
الجه بصوره لا تلبي المطلوب الحقيقي يعني
هذه المفاوضات هي مجرد ترتيبات امنيه لا
تلبي الشروط لوقف الحرب في السودان شكرا
جزيلا للاسف ده وقتنا الدكتور اسامه
عيدروس الاكاديمي السوداني المختص في
الشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه شكرا
وبهذا ننهي الحصاد ونتحول الى عبد السلام
والسي في نشره منتصف الليل